There's a funny thing that sort of quietly
happening, which is that more and more republicans
are just quitting politics in order harder
to at least in part, get away from a Republican
party that's led by Donald Trump and which
might actually reelect Donald Trump to a second
term.
The latest is Texas Congressman Mike Conaway.
He's announced that he's just not going to
try and get reelected in 2020 he's going by
by, and officially he hasn't said yet that
this is about Trump necessarily, but we have
other Republicans on record saying that serving
under Donald Trump is an embarrassment.
We've got former Republican congressman Tom
Davis who told the hill, quote, serving in
the era of Trump has fewer awards.
He has made an already hostile political environment.
Worse every day there is some indefensible
tweet or comment to defend or explain.
It is exhausting and often embarrassing.
We already heard from Paul Mitchell, Pete
Olson, Martha Roby, rob Bishop, Republican
members of Congress that they're just bailing.
They're going away, they're quitting.
You'll remember on the Senate side back in
2018 that Republican Senator Jeff Flake said
he was bailing out after very public spats
with Donald Trump, may have even been 2017
hard to keep track of how quickly things are
happening.
That seat was ultimately lost by Republicans
a and was won by Democratic senator, now Democratic
senator, Kirsten Cinema.
So there are probably some additional opportunities
for Democrats as a result of this.
You, you've got of the five Republican members
of Congress that are retiring for our in pretty
safe Republican districts, Pete Olsen's district
is maybe winnable.
And there's also the possibility that these
Republican members of Congress just kind of
realized that Democrats are probably keeping
control of the house in 2020 maybe even extending
their control.
They're not thrilled with the idea of another
two years out of power, particularly under
Donald Trump.
And so in total, it's not because of Trump
alone, they're just going to bail.
And there's something funny about this, which
is that we've heard rumblings for months about
this, about Republicans who don't want to
be serving under Donald Trump, but if there
were enough of them with a spine instead of
quitting, they could get together and actually
push back against Donald Trump, sort of acting
like the check and balance to the White House
that they're supposed to be instead of merely
being subservient, and I know that in a sort
of strict constitutional sense, there is some
degree of subservience, but I'm using the
term a little bit more colloquially.
I got emails from some people in our audience
saying, I actually respect these politicians
who are leaving because they don't want to
serve under Donald Trump.
That's fine.
I'd respect them more if they stayed and actually
stood up to Trump and changed this path that
the Republican Party has taken in the era
of Trumpism.
Ultimately, whatever the reason is that they're
leaving, it's good in the sense that it's
an opportunity for a seat to be turned democratic.
Even if many of these are safe Republican
seats, it's still sort of early, but soon
we're going to start looking at House and
Senate 2020.
The broad stroke is Democrats are likely to
keep the house.
The question is do they extend their majority
or not?
Democrats are almost 100% not going to take
the Senate.
And I know every time I mentioned this, I
get emails from people who don't seem to get
it.
It's not my opinion of the tone or direction
of the country.
It's only one third of senators are up for
reelection.
Each cycle, the seats that are up for reelection,
this cycle favor Republicans keeping control
of the Senate.
I just don't see any path to Democrats taking
over the Senate in 2020.
The idea would be uh, try to retain the Doug
Jones seat.
Don't lose more than one or two seats net
and then maybe be in a position in 2022 hopefully
with a Democratic president in the White House
at that point to take over control of the
Senate in the mid term.
That will come, uh, in three years.
I guess it is at this point in time.
If you believe Democrats can take the Senate
in 2020 get in touch and tell me how because
I simply don't see it.